hey guys it's Justine and we're back
with another baking video and I am so
hyped about this one this one is super
festive I saw this little Santa cake as
an inspiration on Google I Googled Santa
cake and this was one of the first
things that popped up and it's really
cute and I was looking at it I was like
I think I can do this like there's
really not that much involved okay well
actually there's a little more involved
than I thought maybe I should have
looked a little bit harder before I
started this video anyway let's get
started I was going to make the cake for
you guys on video but like I dumped cake
mix in and mix it up and then bake it
and I didn't want to do that on camera
because it's actually quite boring so I
already pre-made all of the cakes
bye bye cakes and if you thought I was
gonna make homemade icing
no
I even made two red cakes so that we
could have a little Rainbow action
happening now I am so excited because
all this week I'm doing something called
vlogmas where I'm giving away a gift
every single day so check out
ijustine.com vlogmas for all of the ways
to enter
there's also a secret code somewhere
throughout this video that you can use
to get some extra entries in the vlogmas
giveaway now let's get to baking okay
well the baking's already done basically
what I need to do now is color some
icing so let me check my reference Santa
it looks like we need some red some
white we've got these little sprinkles
some little buttons on his little jacket
it looks like we need kind of like a
flesh tone color I'm gonna make my red
icing first I don't really have a plan
of attack also upon further
investigation it seems like they may
have used fondant for some of this which
We're not gonna do oh my God that smells
so good this smells like
140 calories per serving 20 grams of
sugar oh geez
I feel like we're gonna need a pretty
healthy amount of red to cover all of
this
I'm trying to do cake math right now
how much icing I'm going to need I
definitely got extra icing because I
know how these things go
oh no we have creamy Supreme vanilla and
creamy Supreme white there's a little
discrepancy of color we're going to be
dyeing This Thread anyway so I think
it'll I think it'll be okay yeah look at
that can you see the difference oh no
stay in there I think three of these
should be enough
I'm just gonna put one more in I think
just one more no no I think that's good
we're gonna make it work let's put in
some red food coloring get this all
mixed up start you stirring
pour it oh this looks like Dexter was
here
we need more red this has got to be
super red
wow this looks great this consistency is
beautiful no one should ever consume
this amount of red food dye ever in one
sitting
that looks beautiful oh my goodness this
is a great because oh come on now this
is a great consistency okay
okay mix
let's just pour it all in just see what
happens
[Music]
get in there go to your go to your home
it's definitely still pink but we did
use an excessive amount of red food dye
so I think this is going to be good
enough looks good to me icing check this
is where it's gonna get fun because
we're gonna do a couple layers of the
cake bring out our trusty little spinny
mix spinner I haven't done this in so
long I'm so I'm Rusty I'm like a rusty
tea kettle all right I think we're gonna
do white red white red this is a Nifty
little cake leveler if you've never seen
one before pretty freaking cool that
saws the cakes evenly look at this look
at that look at this
what do you know about kick sawing
[Music]
it kind of reminds me of the Westworld
episode when they like cut the scalp and
then they just like lift it up and
they're like oh
first little piece is ready
this is like our little mortar for the
cake house that we're building
Now red cake
this one's thick
what happened to you
there's this guy on Tick Tock that I
watched he cuts down trees he just chops
them down I feel like him right now
wow oh my God that is so red
[Music]
do I open a bakery do I quit everything
I'm doing is this my calling hello I'm
here
[Music]
that's beautiful it's beautiful wow so
talented another cake
coming in
this one's already pretty level that's
nice but we want them to all be
perfectly even because it really matters
it doesn't matter
I'm just gonna dust it off a little
[Music]
another impeccable placement oh my
goodness should I play a sport
like but I get super obsessive about
like making sure it's perfect I'm like
it doesn't matter you're gonna see it
because it's got to be straight
we have one more cake to pile on here
now if I was making this in my actual
Bakery I would definitely load on way
more icing in here but I was a little
concerned that I wouldn't have enough to
complete the decorating so we're going a
little light Santa's watching his
Christmas figure
okay here we go here you go here you go
it's beautiful it's beautiful it's
beautiful perfect this is now where
we're getting down to the nitty-gritty
it looks like there's like a little skin
flesh tone kind of thing like happening
on like half of the cake oh God I don't
know oh boy I don't know what's gonna
happen let me clean up my area and I'm
gonna think about it cake is ready I'm
gonna make the flesh colored Santa skin
now and then we're gonna ice this thing
up so we're gonna put some icing in here
we're not gonna need too much
I don't I don't know I don't know
oh
this may be a little too red what if we
add more yellow
maybe Santa has frostbite there's some
more white in here we'll just maybe we
can use that to even it out a little
I thought a little bit that was actually
quite a lot whatever happens with this
we're sticking with it
[Applause]
that works even if it doesn't I don't
care anymore this works for me we gotta
get decorating we've got our red icing
here I think that I'm still thinking too
much about this and I'm just gonna go
for it we're just gonna do it
so nervous all right so half of this is
going to be his little hat
nice up the sides
and hope for the best
see that was a save that was a save I've
ever seen one this is way more difficult
not icing the whole cake because usually
I'll just go like this and then kind of
put it down the sides but we gotta save
that other side for Santa's skin
my arm's getting tired
okay so things are going pretty well
starting to get super obsessive about it
and I I need to stop because I will be
here all day trying to perfect this
icing just one more just one more one
more round one more round
okay good enough good enough
we gotta we gotta draw the line
somewhere the line has been drawn we're
gonna try to fill this part up here with
Santa's little face I feel like it's
actually turned out not bad
this also doesn't have to be perfect
because this will be covered up with the
white icing okay it actually doesn't
look bad now that it's on here just
hoping I don't smear it into the red too
much or we're gonna be in trouble Have
Yourself a Merry Little Christmas yeah I
think that's good look at that look at
okay I'm not touching it it's good
that's that's I'm happy with that now
we're gonna get the white icing into the
piping bags and go to town this is oh my
God this is actually
I'm pretty excited
okay it's been a while since I've used
piping bags so I don't even know what's
gonna happen this could be like not the
right icing for it we're gonna find out
though let me find out real quick
oh
no it wasn't ready so it looks like they
just put some little splotches around
here
okay that's not that good
that's not I don't know my technique
it's not bad
actually now that I'm taking a step back
[Music]
air bubble that's problematic
my favorite starts okay there we go okay
yeah that's
nice I think I might need more icing oh
my gosh I just don't even know I don't
even know oh I'm stressed out I'm
stressed this is working out way better
than I thought it was going to
all right oh boy this is so scary for me
because this is his this is like the the
main thing
that's nice
yes beautiful
that might be a little too big
it's a little aggressive
love to see it and then he's got one big
poofy
right here
yeah yeah we like that we're so close
now I gotta make the beard I already
have the icing in here but I need a
different tip
hmm so this is the beard tip so maybe
I'll just
do this into this one don't tell Rosanna
I'm doing this she would probably be
offended I feel like this is something
you should not do but it's working
maybe I taught her a trick look at that
Ro
what do you know a lot more than me
start and fall
taken care of very quickly
I have no idea what I'm doing if you're
like wow Justine you look like you know
what you're doing think again
okay okay and he's got like a little
mustache kind of situation Happening
Here
[Music]
and then we'll just kind of fill this in
with a little moment like that that's
nice
looking at like what they have and what
I have like we're pretty close I think
now I just need to put the little
eyeballs and the buttons but we've got a
little problem happening here it's
starting to kind of like run down the
side
oh I better do this quick okay I gotta
sort through here
get out the buttons
so there you go one office actually work
out perfect these are great
beautiful beautiful
and his eyeballs maybe like right there
and right there
[Music]
oh my gosh it's great it's so good look
at that Tada
absolute Talent so here's the final cake
I'm actually really excited how this
turned out this
um I don't know what happened here I
think the icing was a little bit warm
but all things considered I think it's
very beautiful this turned out really
really well I know there are some things
that I could have done a little bit
better but that would have required me
to be here all day working on this cake
we did a good enough job good enough for
me now let's cut into it to see how the
little inside turned out
see what that looks like oh wow look at
that the layers the consistency that's
beautiful that is Art right there I do
feel like if I were to ever do this
again I would definitely get a lot more
icing to put in between but all things
considered I think it turned out pretty
good let's take a bite
there is so much red food coloring in
this thing
I think I'm getting a package delivered
should I offer him some cake okay this
is really good I mean I had no part in
what this tastes like because it's
basically a boxed cake and icing from a
can dude this is incredible like you
can't go wrong
um so good well thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed this
video this was actually so much fun and
I've really enjoyed kind of doing these
baking videos again so if you guys like
this give this video a thumbs up and let
me know in the comments below if you
enjoyed it also I hope that you guys
caught the secret word that was featured
throughout this video make sure you guys
enter that make sure you check out
ijustine.com blogmas to see how you can
get some extra entries into the vlogmas
giveaway don't forget to like comment
subscribe hit the Bell to be notified
when I post new videos and I'll see you
in the next one I'm gonna help myself to
this little cake
foreign